heil en cours le week end dernier le
faire que des coudrais a pris l'alluré
d'un grand magasin un jour de soldes
pris d'assaut par 1500 enfants élan
courtois venu participer à la grande
chasse aux oeufs c'est une chasse aux
oeufs ou
on a distribué six mille the sur tout le
parc des coudrais un oeuf égale un oeuf
en chocolat en échange et nous avons 50
de l'eau donc 52e numérotés et ils
viennent les échanges et ici on a des
places de ciné
on a des places pour france miniature
beaucoup de chocolat une chasse qui
prend parfois des allures de course
l'objectif aujourd'hui ramasser un
maximum de en plastique pour venir
ensuite les échanger contre de
véritables le en chocolat récolté man et
prendre des heures polystyrène et on
vient d'aisé et gérer compte d'autres
des jeunes comme l'a expliqué à mathieu
qu'il était menacé
c'était un petit peu sport avec une
petite fille de 3 ans il fallait se
jeter dans la foule pour pouvoir aller
chercher les oeufs mais non non ce un
bon moment en famille
ici pas de perdant tout le monde a eu
droit à du chocolat
une deuxième édition pour une chasse aux
oeufs qui a su rassembler comme un
échauffement pour les enfants avant que
le lapin de pâques passe dans leur
jardin